>> Geraldo: WE WILL BRING YOU
ANY MEANINGFUL UPDATES ON THE
TRAGEDY GOING ON IN FLORIDA, IN
THE MEANTIME ON A MUCH DIFFERENT
SCALE, BRAND-NEW FALLOUT IN
BRITNEY SPEARS YEARS LONG LEGAL
DRAMA TO BREAK FREE OF HER
CONSERVATORSHIP, SUPPORT POURING
IN FOR THE POP STAR AFTER
DRAMATIC TESTIMONY WHICH SHE
DETAILS WHAT SHE CALLED "ABUSIVE
CONSERVATORSHIP" AND SEVERE
MISTREATMENT BY HER OWN DAD,
TELLING THE COURT SHE HAD NO
CONTROL OVER HER LIFE OR HER
FINANCES, MAKING OTHER EXPLOSIVE
CLAIMS LIKE HOW SHE WAS FORCED
INTO INVOLUNTARY MEDICAL
EVALUATION AND REHAB AND MADE TO
TAKE MEDICATION AGAINST HER
WILL.
SPEARS ALSO SAYING "I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO GET MARRIED, HAVE A
BABY.
I WAS TOLD RIGHT NOW UNDER THE
CONSERVATORSHIP I AM NOT ABLE TO
GET MARRIED OR HAVE A BABY."
KATIE, IT IS ABSOLUTELY
INFURIATING TO ME THAT THEY EVEN
MADE HER HAD AN IUD.
SHE CAN'T EVEN CONTROL HER OWN
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS, IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Katie: THEY ARE FORCING HER
TO BE ON BIRTH CONTROL AND MY
FOLLOW-UP QUESTION TO THAT IS IF
SHE WERE TO GET PREGNANT, WOULD
THEY THEN FORCED HER TO HAVE AN
ABORTION BECAUSE THEY ARE
CONTROLLING THE REST OF HER
LIFE.
CONSERVATORSHIPS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE ABOUT TAKING CARE OF SOMEBODY
WHO CAN'T TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES, THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
MEAN THAT YOU CAN HELP SOMEONE
LIVE A HAPPY LIFE BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT IN A POSITION TO TAKE
CARE OF THEMSELVES IN A PROPER
CAREFUL WAY.
THIS IS NOT THAT, HER TESTIMONY
ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE DONE TO HER,
SHE LIKENED IT TO BEING SEX
TRAFFICKED, BEING STUCK AS A
PRISONER INSIDE HER OWN HOME,
THEY ARE NOT TAKING CARE OF HER
THAT IN A WAY THAT HAS ANYTHING
TO DO WITH LOVING HER OR WANTING
HER TO LIVE THE BEST LIFE THAT
THEY CAN TO HELP HER THROUGH.
WITH THE JUDGE IS GOING TO SAY,
THE RULES AND LAWS OF
CONSERVATORSHIPS ARE BASICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET OUT OF HAND
WHEN I WATCHED THE DOCUMENTARY
"FRAMING BRITNEY SPEARS" AS THEY
SAID SHE WASN'T COMPETENT ENOUGH
TO HIRE HER OWN LAWYER, BUT THEY
ALLOWED HER TO BE COMPETENT
ENOUGH TO SIGN HER ENTIRE LIFE
AWAY FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE AS
A YOUNG WOMAN INTO THIS LIFELONG
CONSERVATORSHIP.
SO EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE SEEN SO
FAR JUST DOESN'T ADD UP IN TERMS
OF BEING ETHICAL OR MORAL OR
BASED IN ANY KIND OF ABILITY TO
TREAT HER FAIRLY.
>> Geraldo: ADMITTEDLY, JESSE,
I DON'T KNOW EVERYTHING.
>> Jesse: GERALDO, COME ON.
>> Geraldo: ABOUT BRITNEY.
I DO KNOW THAT HER FATHER LIKE A
GREEDY, SELF-SERVING, HOW DARE
HE, SHE'S ALMOST 40 YEARS OLD,
SHE'S HAD A CAREER, SHE
GENERATED TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ENTERTAINED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AND HERE SHE
IS, BASICALLY A TO A
CONSERVATORSHIP THAT IS KATIE
INDICATED HAS NO BOUNDS.
>> Jesse: I SPOKE TO A BRITNEY
INSIDER WHO SPENT TIME WITH HER
DURING THE CONSERVATORSHIP, NOT
JOHNNY, I'M NOT GOING TO NAME
HIS NAME BUT HE SAID THE FATHER
BEFORE ALL THIS WAS JUST A CROOK
AND DIDN'T MAKE A LOT OF MONEY,
WASN'T A SOPHISTICATED GUY AND
THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW HE'S NOW
MANAGING A MULTIBILLION DOLLAR
EMPIRE OF HIS DAUGHTER AND IT'S
BEEN 13 YEARS AND HE DOESN'T
WANT TO GIVE IT UP AND THEY HAVE
A SYSTEM SET UP FOR NOW THERE'S
A TEAM OF LAWYERS FOR HIM, TEAM
OF LAWYERS FOR HER, SHE PAYS
BOTH TEAMS OF LAWYERS AND HER
LAWYERS ARE COURT-APPOINTED
LAWYERS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF MONEY
TO GET BEGIN WITH, THEY ARE
GOING TO PROLONG THIS BECAUSE
THEY'VE HIT THE JACKPOT AND IT'S
A CATCH-22, IF THEY SAY, YOU
KNOW, WE ARE GOING TO SEND YOU
FOR AN EVALUATION EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND SHE SAYS NO, I'M FINE, I
DON'T WANT TO DO THAT, SHE'S NOW
SAID SHE'S UNCOOPERATIVE AND
THEN IF SHE GOES AND TALKS TO
THE PEOPLE AT THE THERAPY
SESSION, SAYS OPEN BUT I'M
ANGRY, I'M DEPRESSED," THEN
SHE'S ANGRY AND DEPRESSED AND
NEEDS TO STAY IN THE
CONSERVATORSHIP.
IF YOU ARE INCAPACITATED, YOU DO
THIS TO SOMEONE BUT SHE IS NOT
INCAPACITATED, SHE'S PUTTING ON
SHOWS, SHE'S ACTUALLY PAYING THE
SALARIES OF A MULTITUDE OF
PEOPLE.
ALL SHE WANTS TO DO IS HAVE A
REGULAR LIFE WITH A KID AND A
HUSBAND AND THEY ARE NOT LETTING
HER DO THAT, THEY ARE MAKING HER
WORK LIKE AN ANIMAL FOR THEIR
OWN FINANCIAL INTERESTS.
>> Geraldo: THERE'S ALWAYS,
DANA, TWO SIDES TO A STORY BUT
IT FEELS LIKE THE WEIGHT OF
EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THIS YOUNG
LADY AND HER CHALLENGE TO HAVE
HER FREEDOM BACK.
>> Dana: AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THE CONSERVATORSHIP WAS SUPPOSED
TO HELP HER GET THROUGH A TOUGH
PERIOD, IT WASN'T MEANT TO BE A
LIFE SENTENCE.
HOWEVER, THE FATHER'S LAWYER
SAYS AT ANY POINT, BRITNEY IS
FREE TO FILE UP AS PETITION TO
END THE CONSERVATORSHIP AND
SHE'S NEVER DONE THAT AND THAT'S
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING OR
EVERYTHING.
>> Jesse: I DID SPEAK TO MY
INSIDER ABOUT THAT AND AT
ONE POINT BRITNEY DID GET AN
ATTORNEY FROM THE OUTSIDE
BECAUSE SHE DID WANT TO FILE TO
END IT, BRINGS THE ATTORNEY INTO
THE COURT AND THE JUDGE SAYS NO,
YOU CAN'T USE THAT ATTORNEY, YOU
CAN ONLY USE THE ATTORNEY THAT'S
BEEN APPOINTED.
>> Katie: THE LAWYER NEVER
TOLD HER SHE HAS AN ABILITY TO
GET OUT OF IT.
>> Geraldo: ARE WE RIGHT TO
CARE?
>> Greg: I DIDN'T CONTACT
ANYBODY ON THE STORY, I AM NOT
GOING TO CLAIM TO BE AN EXPERT
IN 5 MINUTES ON LAW.
BEHIND EVERY FAMILY TRAGEDY AS A
TEAM OF LAWYERS PERPETUATING IT.
>> Geraldo: I AGREE AND I'M A
LAWYER.
>> Greg: FAMILY LAW IS
PROBABLY ONE THE MOST TORTUROUS
MAZES OF HELL ANYBODY CAN GO
THROUGH AND I ONLY KNOW THAT
TALKING TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH DIVORCES, THERE'S NO
INCENTIVE -- ALL OF THE STUFF IS
BASED ON INCENTIVES AND THERE'S
NO INCENTIVE FOR LAWYERS TO END
THIS AND YOU BUT TO WONDER AT
THIS POINT WELLS COULD BE JUDGED
INCAPACITATED FOR A YEAR OR
TWO.
I DON'T WANT MY WIFE TO GET ANY
IDEAS BECAUSE I'VE SAID SOME
PRETTY CRAZY THINGS ON THE SHOW
AND MY TWEETS ARE A LITTLE
DISTURBING, SHE COULD PROBABLY
FIND ENOUGH.
THIS IS AN INDUSTRY THAT DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT YOU AS LONG AS YOU
ARE MAKING THEM MONEY, SHE DOES
TWO SHOWS A DAY FOR FIVE YEARS
IN VEGAS, THAT IS GUTFELD
SCHEDULE.
THE WORST OCCUPATION IN THE
WORLD, PROBABLY MORE DANGEROUS
THAN BEING A LOG OR IS CHILD
STAR, IF YOU WENT TO THE NUMBERS
OF ALL CHILD STARS AND FIGURED
OUT WHICH ONES ARE DEAD AND
PERMANENTLY DAMAGE IS PROBABLY A
LOT WORSE THAN PEOPLE WHO ARE
LONGSHOREMEN OR LOGGERS WHICH
HAVE 111 DEATHS IN 100,000 IN
CASE YOU ARE ASKING, THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IS
CODIFIED CHILD ABUSE, THEY DON'T
CARE.
NOBODY CARES.
>> Geraldo: I'M JUST WONDERING
IF IT WAS A FEMALE JUDGE, WOULD
SHE HAVE BEEN MORE SYMPATHETIC
THAN THESE CREEP